[Música]
si eres mexicano
puede ser
y puedes hacer
todo lo que te propongas
te lo voy a repetir de nuevo
si eres mexicano puedes ser y puedes
hacer todo lo que te propongas
el maestro octavio paz
quien fue premio nobel de literatura en
1990 el siglo pasado escribió un libro
que es fundamental para entender la
mentalidad de los mexicanos es el libro
se llama el laberinto de la soledad y en
ese libro
el maestro aborda nuestros miedos
abordan nuestros complejos y explica por
qué muchos de nosotros guardamos una
posición de inferioridad ante otras
naciones ante los retos o incluso ante
la vida misma
te voy a hacer una pregunta y quiero que
la medite es profundamente
has sentido el peso de ser mexicano
alguna vez
me dedicado a la publicidad por más de
18 años y a veces el simple hecho de ser
mexicano te hace sentir más pequeño
dentro de una sala de juntas oa la hora
de presentar una idea ante un cliente
extranjero oa la hora de crear una idea
que hable de nuestra cultura porque
pensamos que un cliente jamás va a
comprar algo que demuestre tanto nuestro
espíritu de ser mexicanos
a veces el peso de ser mexicanos se
siente profundamente ante otros
mexicanos
dicen ahora que el peor enemigo de un
mexicano exitoso es otro mexicano con
una cuenta en twitter
yo no sé a este sentimiento lo describe
el maestro octavio paz
no como inferioridad sino como soledad
y así estamos muchos de nosotros solos
así nos sentimos que no hay un eco de
nuestras ideas de nuestras creencias de
nuestros sueños
el maestro octavio paz escribió
que una obra de arte
o una acción concreta definan más al
mexicano que la más penetrante de las
descripciones
si te pones a pensar
desde los años 50 es el maestro octavio
pasa manera de profecía describía
este sentimiento
y nos hablaba de cómo nos íbamos a
sentir en un momento de nuestras vidas
pero saben qué
la cosa ha cambiado
de pronto todas aquellas penetrantes
descripciones que alguna vez escuché
escuchaste perdón o sentiste en tu vida
se han ido tornando en elogios y en
oportunidades para nosotros los
mexicanos
te voy a contar una historia
yo un simple ciudadano un día me
encontré dinero tirado
pero una bolsita venían cinco mil pesos
y cuatro fotografías
y dije con esto es muy probable que yo
pueda encontrar a los dueños de este
dinero probablemente es una familia que
lo perdió para hacer trámite
así que a través de las redes sociales
organizó una campaña que se llamaba
operación chapultepec
en menos de 12 horas ya había sido
compartido por una cantidad tremenda de
influencers incluso la banda el recodo
columna marta de baile y un montón al de
gente
mía bien escrito a través de facebook
para decirme yo los conozco yo sé dónde
viven yo sé dónde trabajan y pude
localizar a la familia
y dije guau lo logré perfecto al día
siguiente
bosch fish me acompañó a entregarle el
dinero a esta familia en el mismo lugar
donde lo habían perdido que había sido
en la avenida reforma frente al museo de
antropología justamente en chapultepec
pero la cosa no para hoy
de pronto mi historia atrajo la atención
de muchos medios tenía milenio tenía a
100 él tenía el país entrevistándome me
hicieron un fitur en tv azteca para
preguntarme por qué te volviste ese
dinero esa era la noticia un mexicano
devuelve dinero
de pronto la honestidad se hizo viral
porque un mexicano se atrevió a romper
el paradigma hizo lo que rara vez un
mexicano puede hacer
el nuestro cambio paz dice esto en el
libro el laberinto de la soledad en
lugar de interrogarnos a nosotros mismos
no sería mejor crear obrar sobre una
realidad que nos entrega al que la
contempla sino al que es capaz de
sumergirse en ella
lo que nos habla el maestro es que no
debemos abstraernos de nuestra realidad
necesitamos abrazarla abrazar nuestros
complejos nuestro contexto y nuestros
problemas para entenderlos con
profundidad y es entonces cuando va a
operar en nosotros un cambio y vamos a
poder dar el salto que estamos esperando
al pensar en esto y en todas las cosas
que la gente me escribió en facebook
donde me decían estas mentiras
seguramente son es una historia
inventada te dedicas a hacer cosas en
social media y te dedicas a vidal y
sharm acá seguramente esto es un invento
porque el dinero yo no lo hubiera
devuelto
ahí entendí que era importante hacer
algo
transmitirle a otras personas de qué
manera pueden cambiar este paradigma
recuerdan este experimento
fue tal vez cuando iba en segundo o el
tercer año de primaria cuando recuerdo
haber tenido que conseguir diez frascos
de papilla comer papilla de manzana
durante dos días etiquetarlos del 1 al
10 comprar algodón y mi mamá me ayudó a
hacer las madejas de algodón y
colocarlos en cada frasco y por un
frijolito y colocar el agua
y observarlos tienes que observar tienes
que estar allí diariamente para ver
si esa plantita salía ahora el
experimento se trataba de poner
cantidades diferentes de agua y de
algodón en cada frasco para que tú
seleccionar a aquellos que tú creías
formuladas la hipótesis y decías va a
crecer en este y en este entonces los
apartados y finalmente cuando la planta
crecía hacia es otra cosa cada elemento
de este experimento nos habla de algo
por ejemplo
la semilla o el frijolito nos habla de
la idea o del sueño que tú tienes
el algodón nos habla del conocimiento o
de la experiencia que hemos adquirido el
frasco es nuestro contexto es nuestra
realidad
el agua nos habla de perseverancia nos
habla de ahínco y nos habla de las ganas
que tenemos diariamente de hacer las
cosas ese combustible de nuestras ideas
y de nuestros sueños y obviamente la
planta simboliza la meta
yo lo llamo que a un camino creador
porque se llama el camino creador
lo primero que tienes que hacer en este
experimento es generar una gran cantidad
de posibilidades y soñar sin límites
este mes todas las ideas que puedas
tener aprender todo lo que puedas
aprender porque porque es lógico que
dentro de todo esto dentro de esta
cantidad y de la cantidad de agua y de
algodón que puedas agregar vamos a tener
que buscar la calidad y vamos a tener
que encontrar esas dos o tres cosas
máximo donde eres muy bueno aquellas
cosas que te satisfacen que te salen
naturalmente que te son fáciles y con
las que te sientes feliz y pleno pero la
cosa no para ahí
porque recuerdo perfectamente que la
maestra nos pedía bueno ya creció su
planta perfecto ahora traigan una maceta
con tierra otra con piedras y otra con
arena y vamos a trasplantar esa plantita
y eso es lo que muchas veces nos
paraliza le tenemos miedo al cambio le
tenemos miedo a modificar nuestro
contexto hay unos de donde estamos hacer
las cosas de manera diferente pero
cuando lo hacemos cuando nos atrevemos
cuando tenemos la valentía de dar el
salto ocurren cosas increíbles
crecemos
florecen
ahora bien que mexicano ha pasado por
todas y cada una de estas etapas tomemos
por ejemplo alejandro gonzález iñárritu
alejandro como muchos de nosotros
comenzó haciendo de todo y no todo le
salía bien fue locutor fue reportero fue
redactor fue publicista
y de pronto él se dio cuenta de que era
muy bueno haciendo dirección el 1º piso
hacer muchas cosas soñar aprender
pero cuando descubrió la dirección creyó
en él
y esto es muy importante que tengas una
concepción que tengas la creencia
profunda de que lo que tú traes adentro
esa punzada ese soy bueno en esto te
haga moverte en primera instancia y
perseguir ese camino
pero después le pasó lo que le pasa a
muchos mexicanos lo que le pasa a los
futbolistas cuando están a punto de
meter el penal
que les va a dar el pase
se quedó solo
su guionista lo dejo y en ese momento él
tuvo varias maneras de proceder tal vez
cambiar de trabajo tal vez cambiarse de
país tal vez buscar una maceta nueva
para su planta
todos sabemos lo que pasó
y alejandro se rodeó de gente
talentosísima
y cambio su paradigma dejo de hablar del
drama humano y comenzó a hacer guiones
totalmente diferentes a los que venía
haciendo él es el ejemplo claro de que
se puede crear una realidad nueva de que
de verdad nosotros tenemos el poder de
modificar nuestro contexto avanzar y
trascender muchísimo más lejos de lo que
cada uno de nosotros ha pensado o
querido
él es el ejemplo de que podemos querer
el que podemos creer y de que podemos
crear
quienes queremos ser o lo que queremos
hacer
y se llama camino creador
porque es un llamado a no permanecer
solos ni estáticos es un llamado a la
acción
es un llamado a utilizar las nuevas
tecnologías para viralizar la honestidad
el trabajo la tecnología la ciencia
no necesitas ser famoso siquiera
necesitas tener una convicción plena y
profunda en lo que estás haciendo hoy
para dar el salto
esta es la nueva realidad
esto es lo que todos y cada uno de
nosotros estamos llamados a hacer en
esta nueva era en la era de las redes
sociales en la era de la hiper
comunicación en la era de las
herramientas donde todos y cada uno de
nosotros podemos crear la realidad que
queremos
yo los voy a invitar a ponerse de pie ya
declarar conmigo lo que voy a decir
yo lo digo y ustedes lo repiten
hacen una mano y digan yo quiero
yo creo
yo creador
y ahora cada uno de ustedes están
llamados a crear un país mejor
junto al ser humano que está parado a su
lado
[Aplausos]